Speaker 1: All right, let's get back to the
phones last show before Thanksgiving, we're
going to hear from a bunch of different people.
David Pakman dot com slash discord is the
place where you can contact me.
Let's go right into it and see what's on people's
minds.
Let's go to Is it Bora or Burrow from Miami,
Florida?
Bora, from Miami, you're on the air.
Please unmute and you'll be able to talk to
me.
And last chance for Bora from Miami, Florida,
last opportunity to unmute yourself.
And that's too bad.
Let's go to Matt from Northern California.
Matt, you're on the air next.
Speaker 2: Hey, check one two.
David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: You're coming in loud and clear,
Matt.
Speaker 2: David, thanks, man, I appreciate
you taking the call.
Pleasure.
So as stated, I live in rural Northern California.
We're about two hours north of San Francisco.
Speaker 1: And so is that like Humboldt County
pot area
Speaker 2: just south, I'm part of the Emerald
Triangle, Mendocino County, actually, that
that'll be Meadow Humble and Trinity County.
Got it.
You know it a little bit.
So from where I'm sitting, it's just this
really interesting nexus of rural sort of
urban resentment mixed in with this infusion
of kind of back to land.
Berkeley liberal.
Organic.
Kind of a culture clash.
And with that, the the specific political
moment we're in, I think, is this confusing
identity crisis for especially like rural
satellite counties of the Bay Area in Northern
California, there's there's a lot of resentment
towards San Francisco.
You know, the the rash of organized starts
recently, these the COVID lockdowns.
But and also there's this kind of libertarian
common denominator in the resentment that's
despite sort of some trappings of maybe some
Trumpism.
They're generally pro-gay marriage, they're
pro cannabis.
But then sort of on the other political side,
they're pro firearm ownership.
So, you know, I guess I'm just kind of curious
about your perspective, David, on what democratic
messaging can do to start letting these.
I think there's a huge place in the Democratic
Party platform for a lot of these ideas, but
there are some sort of communication breakdown,
a disconnect, and I'd love to know your thoughts
on messaging.
Have we given up on these populations?
Is there an approach that you can see an inroad
to get them considering the blue ticket?
Speaker 1: Well, I hate to say this because
it's such an important issue, but if you are,
you're talking about strategy, which is great.
I love it.
If we want to talk about strategy, you probably
don't want to attack guns and gun owners.
I mean, it's crazy to say it, but as we've
looked at in a number of studies, when the
topic of guns is a factor in elections, it
tends to be good for Republicans and bad for
Democrats, and it serves as a disincentive
for people to vote for Democrats.
So.
I'm the ultimate pragmatist, I'm not saying
gun safety doesn't matter, I'm not saying
we don't have a massive gun safety issue in
the U.S. we do.
But after the Sandy Hook shooting with Barack
Obama being president had, the House and Senate
still weren't able to get universal background
checks passed even with like 88 or 90 percent
American support for it.
That doesn't mean I'm saying we give up on
the issue at all.
Maybe it means you deal with it at the state
level, or I'm not sure.
But for the group you're talking about where
gun ownership is an issue.
Don't alienate people by talking about guns
and making it central.
Make economic issues central, etc.
And again, I know people will be mad at me
and they'll say David.
But the gun issue matters.
I agree it matters, but I think it's bad strategy,
and it only serves to mobilize Republicans
and others who might otherwise vote for Democrats
but don't want to because of the perception
that they're hostile to guns.
So I think that's how I would start making
inroads with the group that you're describing
that.
Speaker 2: David, can I ask a follow up question?
Yes, of course.
Regarding the specific issue of cannabis and
the Democratic Party, we've found this really
strange stalemate that's emerged regarding
the federal legalization of cannabis, and
recently my understanding is there has been
some talk on the Beltway of even Republicans
starting to come out in support of the federal
legalization.
Yes.
And I guess I have a concern that where, you
know, the Democrats could have put that feather
in their cap and the cans gotten kicked long
enough that, you know, maybe maybe the Republicans
will pick up the can and put that feather
in their cap.
So there's two
Speaker 1: sides to that.
There's two sides that.
So you're rightly pointing out, Hey, you know
what?
Democrats could have done more on federal
marijuana, maybe not legalization, but at
least decriminalization before Republicans
start working on it and saying, We want that
too.
The thing is, I don't know that without Republican
help, Democrats would really have been able
to get it done.
So I actually am not sure about that.
But I do think that increasingly at minimum,
decriminalization is is becoming more and
more bipartisan, which is a great thing.
I don't care who's in favor of it.
Let's get it done.
Speaker 2: Thank you, David, I appreciate
your thoughts.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
There's Matt from Northern California with
a very powerful phone call coming in.
Let's go.
Oh, I don't know.
Let's try Mike from Massachusetts.
Mike, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hey, David, can hear me.
Yes, I can.
Glad to be back.
Called in last week, we had a good talk.
I had a question regarding kind of like the
larger scheme, like not too much larger scheme,
larger scope of like the future of the United
States.
So we've seen over the last 20 years maybe
a little bit more that there is a slow but
steady general trend towards not just like
diversification of the population, but also
just like it's like a little more younger
generations as they come up to be a be a voting
age, but tend to be more liberal, more progressive
than, yes, previous generations.
And overall, they're slowly gaining ground.
But what we've also seen is that as far as
that, as that builds up the hostility and
extremity of, you know, the right wing and,
you know, maybe some people more willing to
take action against what they perceive to
be unethical or immoral people and policies
also seems to be strengthening as well.
And I guess my question is, do you see a point?
Where do you see a point where this small
but dangerous contingent of the right reaches
a point where they see they are ultimately
going to lose the culture war?
They're going to lose like the like the overall
where the country swings in terms of politics
and just where they ultimately reach a point
where they just say we have to, at least in
their minds, we have to save the country and
actually take action like they've been talking
about for a while.
When do you think there's a point coming of
that?
Speaker 1: I would go further.
I think it's already started, but for now,
there aren't that many of them that are just
willing to willy nilly go and be violent.
Yet I think a lot of them are doing the violent
rhetoric.
I think a lot of them see themselves as at
a certain point, we will have to go and become
violent in the real world.
Some of them have.
But yeah, I think that it's an absolutely
legitimate concern.
And when you look at long term demographic
trends, things are changing.
And short of killing people, which I'm against
and think is disgusting, there's a question
as to how are they going to be able to resist
it or push back against it.
And I think they're going to become more radicalized.
I think they're going to become more insular.
A lot of this rhetoric has gone totally mainstream.
I mean, remember the clips of Tucker Carlson
saying on Fox News immigrants make the country
dirtier and poorer and stuff like that.
So.
Yes, I don't think it's hyperbolic to be worried
that they're going to go even crazier as these
changes continue to happen in the United States.
And it's very scary.
Speaker 2: So a follow up question, if I may.
So we've seen a couple countries that used
to be solid democracies and now are only ostensibly
democracies and essentially are autocracies.
The two prime examples in my mind right now
are.
And maybe there's more, but the two prime
are Poland and Belarus.
Now, I don't know the injury.
I don't know the careful details of their
constitutions, what kind of checks and balances
they ever had in place and whatnot, obviously,
that those could cause differences.
But I mean, do you see?
Do you see something like what's happened
in Poland?
Theoretically possible here in the United
States?
Well, the
Speaker 1: degree to which it's
Speaker 2: happened, I think part, I
Speaker 1: think Belarus maybe is a better
example, but it's not.
It's not a hypothetical in the sense that
the U.S. for the first time a few days ago,
we covered this story on Tuesday was added
to the list of backsliding democracies for
the first time ever.
Speaker 2: Oh, I missed that story, but it's
disconcerting to know it's happening.
Speaker 1: It's happening now, unfortunately.
And what we mean by backsliding.
Democracy is a slide towards authoritarianism,
so it's not.
Sadly, it's not a hypothetical.
It's actually happening.
And the question is, how far will it go?
Obviously, I hope it doesn't go as far as
it's gone in Belarus.
But that is that is happening already and
it's horrifying.
Speaker 2: One more, and then I promise I'll
let you move on, I know you got a lot of people
waiting.
If that were to happen, do you see?
Do you see a possibility where the United
States, as in the 50 states, no longer exists
down the road?
And I don't mean like they've torn, they've
torn themselves apart from war?
I mean, if something like what happens in
Belarus, as you just said, possibly happens
here and we continue down this backsliding
democracy path.
Do you think that certain states that like,
say, New England and the Northeast, or maybe
the West Coast attempt to leave and get away
from this backsliding democracy?
Or do you think that the OR do you think that
whoever is trying to take control in an authoritarian
kind of way forces their hand to stay?
Speaker 1: You know, my view on that is these
are essentially random guesses.
Humans are so bad at making that type of prediction,
which is why why I say, you know, when Trump
would say at the State of the Union, the US
will never be a socialist country, never is
a really long time.
And historically nations fail things that
are completely inconceivable take place.
I have absolutely no idea on that, and I'm
not going to pretend to really have an educated
guess because I think we just don't know anything's
possible.
Speaker 2: OK, fair enough.
I appreciate your time, I'm sure a lot of
people are waiting to call in, so I'm sure
I'll be calling again and have a good Thanksgiving.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thanks, Mike.
Likewise, Mike from Massachusetts with a number
of important questions.